hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the final round of
the Isle of Man check on a tournament
the the Swiss one we have Wang Hao
versus David Howell David have won a
very nice game against Alexander Grisha
yesterday and both of them are basically
fighting for a spot in the candidates
tournament so without further ado let's
let's check it out
one cow with the white pieces opens with
d4 we have Knight to f6 c4
we have g6 and now g3 preparing Tiffin
get to the light square Bishop Bishop to
g7 and Bishop to g2 Howell goes for d5
Daniel groom Phil defense something he
often enjoys playing we've see Tetris on
d5 Knight captures on d5 and now Knight
to f3
we have Knight back to b6 just going
back with the night and now comes
castles by white we have Knight to c6
putting pressure on the d4 pawn and now
III just defending that pawn with E 5 by
Howell attacking the center and the now
comes nice to see 3 finally developing
the other night he captures on d4 Knight
captures on d4 Knight dr. sandy for a
capture Sundy for Enda now c6 you cannot
capture the d4 pawn either with the
queen or with the bishop because you run
into a lot of trouble for example Queen
captures Bishop captures Knight b5 puts
you in a really terrible position
there's no way to defend both threats
every but should be 5 just rook e1 so
that's completely winning and if you're
wondering about Bishop captures it's
still nice to be 5 it's just a very
unpleasant move the bishop is under
attack twice you have to move it now
characters captures with check once you
block it now again you go after the c7
pawn and there is not much you can do it
sure you can save the pawn but after
this check the King has to go here and
then with the when the rooks come to the
D and E file it will just be
overwhelming for the black king so
that's why you don't capture it so c6
now you know making this bishop a less
useful piece and also preventing d5 but
here comes d5 so there you have it
see captors on d5 Knight captures on d5
and now a black just castles as the
black King has been in the center of the
board for a bit too long so castles and
the
Bishop to e3 by Avon Hall and here
Knight captures on d5 is a known move in
the position but here Bishop to e6 is a
new move by Howell and it is most
certainly something that he prepared so
it is as a move 14 that we have a
completely new game we have Knight
captures on b68 capture some basics
getting a semi-open file for the rook
and now Bishop captures on b7 rook
captures on a2 we have route captors and
a2 and Bishop captures and a2 and here
Queen to a4 saying okay I'm gonna attack
your bishop so would you play here and
it seems like this is the moment where
the game really begins if Bishop to e6
the game just continues everything is
perfectly fine the material on the board
is equal both players have a bishop pair
so anything can happen here and it's a
pretty symmetrical position you know the
King side the bone structure is is the
same impose upon so really it would be
hard to get a more symmetrical position
with this many pieces on the board but
we have instead of Bishop to these
Bishop d6 Bishop to d5 offering a trade
of light square bishop s-- which makes
sense you want to get rid of white
flight square bishop as all of the
lights pro weaknesses will then be felt
but it runs into a very unpleasant move
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this very unpleasant move well I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations as it is a very
unpleasant move its rook to d1 for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
now I I don't haven't seen the interview
after the game as I don't know if how
overlooked this or did he decide to do
it but I think I think it was a blunder
otherwise it was a really just a crazy
idea because here he has no he has no
moves the bishop will Foley there's no
way to defend the bishop so here Bishop
captures on b7 how sacrifices the Queen
will rook captures on the 8th route
character son d8 and now okay he has a
look in the light square bishop for the
Queen it's not the end of the world
especially since you still have the
bishop pair we have f4 by white now
making an additional safety square for
for your King and Bishop captures and b2
so grabbing yet another pawn so if you
could get your Bush room back to g7 some
get this Bishop over to e6 and start
pushing your passport then this game is
it then this is anyone's game but of
course that one cow will have his say
about that Queen to e7 attacking the
bishop and the pawn on d6 with rook to
the 7 and now Queen captures and b6 also
attacking the bishop here so without
wasting any time
not allowing how to consolidate with
Bishop to a1 and now comes Queen to b5
again putting pressure on the rook here
and also the rook has to keep an eye on
the bishop on d7 so the strongest idea
for Howell here is Bishop to ca this
would be the most resilient now prepare
the bishop to reach some light force
here and you can always go for rook to
d1 check but hala went for rook to d1
check immediately we have King to have
to end now Bishop to h1 getting the
bishop to a safe square as well the
Queen has a lot of checks at her
disposal so you never know when you
might blunder a piece so Bishop to h1
and sure it's controlling a lot of
squares here around the black king or a
white king also the route controls a lot
of squares so it could be could be
unpleasant if if how will gets a few
moves in but Queen t8 check King to g7
and now Bishop to c5 threatening Bishop
to f8 check so you have to make some
some more room for a king with h5 and
now Bishop the f8 check so what do you
do here obviously you don't want to go
anywhere - at age 7 or something like
that you're gonna lose the f7 pawn but
no square is a good square here we'll
kink the f6 by Howell and now Queen to
e7 with check King to f5 and Queen
captures on f7 with the check so now if
King e4 you're just gonna capture here
with the check King d4 and now Queen to
c2 now and you run into a lot of trouble
the rook is now captured trapped there's
no good square for the rook you have to
go here and then just check when the
material whatever you whatever you do is
gonna lose the bishop and then it's just
game over so after Queen captures on f7
Bishop to f6
but now you just attack the pin piece
Bishop the e7 is played and here however
of course very disappointed with him as
he it was a very important game for him
you know a chance for a spot at the
candidates and he he blundered and
the sacrifices Queen so he played rook
to d2 check it's still not over
I mean you still have to make white work
for a group capture some h2 now clearing
the G for square 4 for his king with
Queen captures on f6 with check King to
g4 and now Queen captures and g6 with
check King to h3 and now
f5 here how long--how starts to push his
past pawn with the shot back to d5 and
here comes f6 there's a really no good
way to prevent the pawn from being
pushed with King to g2 and now we have
Queen to c2 check and it was in this
position that David Howe resigned the
game whatever he does loses the bishop
and then just the game for example if
you go to a to h3 just Queen to 5 check
picks up the bishop and if you don't if
you play King back to g1 or somewhere
else on the unforced Frank just queen d1
again you pick up the bishop on d5 and
then it's just very much straight
forward so after Queen to c2 check shall
resign the game and a really tough break
for him as you know you know you just
don't expect to play in a Swiss
tournament and you know win a spot at
the candidates that's just insane and
but that's exactly what happened to one
Hall and now China will have two
representatives at the candidates
tournament in England and one cow which
is you know great for them
so the really really tough break this is
Bishop to d5 move like I said it was up
to East six the game just continues it
can go on forever you know and it
probably would but Bishop to d5 just
just just a terrible blunder for for
Howell in in such an important game but
like I always say it's chess you know
things happen and anything can happen
when you play chess
not only does one ha win a spot in the
of his pot and kettle a candidates
tournament but also he wins the Isle of
Man chess tournament because he has he
has a better rating performance than
than Fabiana Caruana
so very big accomplishment for him but
I'm pretty sure about this I'm not 100%
sure so I will probably make another
video from one of the nicer games from
the isle of man chess tournament
tomorrow and then we're going to check
out all of this
but as usual you can check out the
standings I will put a link it in the
description below so you can just check
them out for ourselves so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I'm very
sure how well didn't but one cow on the
other hand congratulations to him and
you know if you meet Maximus really grab
the life library or the bar
congratulate him a happy birthday so I
would like to thank Michael dinner for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage well not
continuing but showing at least one more
game from the albumen chess tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and we are soon starting our
next big saga so I'm gonna have to
create some sort of a poll for you guys
so you can vote so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day